Pocket damage. We were terrified. Jamie,
you were telling me about w w what was
the rap concert where the girl got on
stage and she was saying, yeah, the
Kendrick Lamar concert, which uh,
so I guess this was a
song that happens a lot.
You can see lots of videos of
the crowds singing all the words,
which has a lot of N words
in it, including white
people in the crowd. Correct.
Yeah, lots of, well that's the
way. Mainly white. Yeah. So, uh,
it has videos of Alabama.
Yeah, I'll, I'll pull one up.
I was never talking about cops in
Alabama. The hangout Fest, right.
Little girl up on a stage.
She was obviously drunk.
I like kind of almost
set her up to, to do it.
And as soon as she said like
two or three times he stopped,
it stopped the whole thing. Well,
what, what did she say reference to?
It's in the song. So she sits on
[inaudible], she was doing like karaoke,
like a song lyric. I'll pull up the
videos and then he turned on her.
Oh no, no, no, no. That's not for you.
That's only for me. Oh wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait. Yeah. That's
meme having her up.
I had a bit from 2009 yeah.
My a spike TV special. Hold on
here. A woman gets on stage.
You ready?
Oh, she's going to do it. Oh my God.
She's just, he set her up. Yeah.
It's terrible.
He's mocking her already. Yeah.
Wow. She must be so now
we play in this. Get pulled.
Jesus Christ. Wait, wait, wait.
That's terrible. It's crazy,
bro. You have to park. You got a
bleak one. Single word. Oh, I'm sorry.
I'm stuck. Sorry.
His ass get off there. They're
all of the thumbs down. Get off.
You said the noise and he says that
we love, you can't say the noise.
That's mostly it. Meme
in hilarious and preposterous
times. I mean that
is so strange. That is his song. Yeah.
He wrote his song. He wrote the words.
She loves him. She loves him. She's at
his concert. He gave her the microphone,
played the song.
She's singing the song that
he loves that he wrote.
Now audience loves and everybody's
like, you did the wrong thing.
You made the noise. So wow
man. [inaudible] crowd doing it though.
This whole crowd is looks
mostly white girls screaming.
Okay, so how's that word? Got
a double standard. I don't,
this is why I stay at home. Wait
a minute. How does that work?
So there's a lot of people
there. Yeah, you can do it.
You can do it if there's a
bunch of people there. Yeah,
but you can't do it if
you're by yourself. No.
Onstage by herself in front of
those people. You can't do it.
But if you're in with them you could
do it. Yes. And that was mostly white.
That was a lot of white there.
And of course in that one,
white people were ridiculous. So
confused. So confused. I mean,
this is a strange time. I
was going to say I did this,
a spike TV special in
2009 and there was a,
do you remember that old
commercial with a, the girl,
the girl comes home and her dog
started talking to her like Lindsey,
I really wish you wouldn't smoke pot.
You're not the senior. You smoke pot in a,
I miss my friend. I had this
whole thing where I was like,
I was like, first of all, whatever
that chick's on, she's not on pot.
Cause if you were on pot, you'd be like,
wait a minute, my fucking dog can talk.
All right, how long have you
been able to talk to God?
You my whole fucking life. Your whole
life. This is the first shit you said,
right? You know,
and I went through this whole thing and
I called my dog a faggot and I'm this
guy. This was like in the beginning
of political correctness, right?
Cause it was 2009 he, this is
a gay guy said to me, he goes,
you can't say that word. That's
our n****r. That's our word. Right?
That's what he said. Right. He
literally said, I go, wait a minute.
What did you just say? And he said
it again. He said, it's our n****r.
We're allowed to say it.
You can't say it. I go,
that's the gay shit I've ever heard.
And he started laughing. I go,
that's so crazy. I go, I'm
talking to a dog. I'm talking,
I'm angry at a dog because I've
had this dog my whole life.
His first words out of his mouth. I
tell you I love you every day and,
and what do you say? You say, I wish you
wouldn't smoke weed. Fuck you stupid.
I smoke weed and I go to work and I
pay for your food faggot. That was,
that was the joke and he
got, he got like, I'm like,
these rules are preposterous,
isn't it supposed to be about intent
of kids and it's supposed to be a bike.
I'm supposed to be conveying how I feel
and the words are supposed to mirror my
thoughts. Right? Like when you
have magic that you can't say,
and in this case with the N word,
it's even crazier because it's
like some people could say it,
you could say it sometimes. Sometimes
you can't say it, it's too heavy.
But black people could
say it, why people can't.
But why people can say it if we're in
the crowd and they're yelling it out,
but as long as it's an a on the end of it.
Yeah, right, exactly. The ER
is what gets you in trouble.
Well look, racism is
disgusting. All racism,
racism against Chinese people,
racism against white people.
Racism against every, of
course against black people,
of course against everyone judging
someone on something that they have no
control over. That's
what it is like you are,
well you're born whenever you're
born, Irish, German, Italian, African,
you're born, it's not you. You
are just who you are. Right?
So racism is disgusting. But is that,
is it racism?
When you have that girl on stage and she's
singing that song that she loves that
you sing, it's your song. Like
that's not really racism. No.
So when she's singing along and
everybody's [inaudible] you racist,
you fucking Nazi. Like
what are we doing? Right?
Cause this is what we're
doing here is we're we,
we've gone into some
ridiculous zone where it's not,
it doesn't make any sense cause
we know that's not her intent.
No, exactly right. This is the,
becomes an intellectual exercise.
It becomes like a word game.
It's a little puzzle kind of thing
that we're doing to trap this person.
You could say she's very innocent up
there. They all know she's a little drunk.
It's kind of like setting someone up to
do something. Yeah, it's pretty gross.
Weird. But it's weird
that it's so universal.
Like that crowd that was
probably 20,000 people. No,
I had a weird thing on,
uh, you know, I'm, I, I'm,
I'm on the show live from here,
the prayer old Prairie home
companion show and uh, you know,
I'm the writer for it and stuff, had right
around it and appear on it and stuff.
Anyway, uh, I'm very involved
with the show. Uh, Chris,
who's this bluegrass guy who
plays a mandolin, who's a amazing,
kindest person you'd ever
meet, like super, super sweet,
sweet person, like, like
Mr. Rogers in a way.
Like it's to that level of kindness and
he sings everybody's birthdays and stuff
and he sings different songs. And
uh, as a tribute to everything,
he loves all music. He loves everything.
He sang a Kendrick Lamar song,
he sang a little bit of it, uh, in like,
cause it was his birthday that week and
he got so much hate online that a white
person can't be singing that song.
What is the song about? It's a,
I don't know, but it wasn't, that
wasn't the thing. It was the word.
It was that he was, um,
what's the thing that you take
some cultural appropriation
that he's not allowed
to sing and meanwhile he's
singing bluegrass Indian music.
I mean the from all around the world.
This is a kind soul celebrating and it
really freaked him out
cause he is so nice.
He couldn't believe the hate that he got
from it that now he's super sensitive
about singing that music
at all. It's not logical.
It's not when you have to put your
foot down and you consider the source
culturally we have to put our foot
down because we're going down this very
strange,
illogical road where you can just
decide what's evil and what's bad and it
doesn't have any bearing on the thought
or the intent behind it is, look,
they went after Bruno
Mars. Like get in the,
just get the fuck outta here. Yeah.
They accused Bruno Mars of cultural
appropriation. What culture.
He's everything. He's
everything. Meanwhile,
what is he doing where anybody would
accuse him of cultural appropriation.
He sings these beautiful fucking
songs. Oh, he's a lightless world.
He's amazing. Yes. I love that guy.
The guy's amazing voice is fantastic
and his songs are fun and they're catchy
and the, I love listening to them.
I saw him in Vegas in concert.
It was just the most
uplifting, bright thing.
You know what made me happy though is
that a bunch of black artists said,
fuck you. He's great. Like
what was the original charge?
Just fucking social justice warriors.
We're going after him for
cultural appropriation.
All these like super progressive, angry
fuck heads. We decide culture, whatever,
man. It doesn't have to make
sense. This is the thing.
They're just looking for targets. It
doesn't have to make sense. This is not a,
it's not like a logical progression.
Like, Oh, Bruno Mars is steep.
It's not like, Oh,
he's stealing from these old blues
singers and he's not crediting them.
And he's, Oh, come on,
white guy from Kentucky.
That's not what we're
dealing with you. Right?
We're dealing with a multiracial guy who
sings these beautiful songs that they
don't, they're not cultural appropriation.
Even if he was white and yet, no,
exactly. It's just a joy of music
and music is a mix of everything.
It's a mix of all of us of
everything that is good. Right.
Coming out saying like his style. But
if that's the case then here's the case.
I'm a fucking huge fan of the
black keys. The black keys.
Oh a lot of their shit is blues.
A lot of that is old blues.
Like it sounds so similar to
some great old blues. Sure.
Is that cultural appropriation?
I mean I love them.
I mean you saying they should stop
doing what I what? I love to hear.
No come on. I mean what are we doing?
Yeah, that's crazy. But what is,
what did you know what
the other part of it is?
How many people are really
complaining about that stuff?
It's a very small amount but it's so small
but it's enough where your friend got
scared. He did get scared and it literally
amounts to probably three tweets.
You know what I mean? It's like, but
those people, that's the only noise.
People aren't saying
wow I love that version.
Cause they just like it
in the normal people.
It's these haters that just want to do
it and but the people in control of it
have to calm him and make him realize
we've got your back days wrong.
They'll fucking fire him
if it gets loud enough.
It doesn't have to make any sense.
That's where it squirrely too.
They fired speaking to Prairie home
companion. They fired Garrison Keillor.
I know they fired him,
removed his name for everything because
he hugged a lady and her his hand went
down her back and then he apologized,
sent her an email. She said it's fine.
They went back and forth with
it. Didn't do anything else.
No history of sexual harassment,
sexual assault, no history of anything.
Terrible. Years later when all
this me too stuff comes out,
she comes out with that. Yeah, it was
dirty business. Yeah, it was dirty.
It's dirty, but it's
doesn't, it's not logical.
It's like there's this fever feeding
frenzy that goes on with these things.
It's a mob mentality.
Yeah. It just want to tear people
down. They want to tear up.
I really believe that you have to in
all these situations is consider the
source. Like you really have to consider,
it's like when the
steroid thing went down,
there were like people came at Barry bonds
harder than everybody else because he
had a rap for not being a good guy.
He people did not like him regardless
of that. So when it happens,
people kind of come after him harder
than they came after Sammy Sosa. Uh,
yes and yeah. And much harder than
like Andy Pettitte or you know,
these letters.
He's a pitcher for the Yankees and it's
just like a nice guy and they don't
care, you know. But if
somebody is a problem,
Jose Conseco Jose can say it was a
problem cause he ratted everybody out.
Oh yeah, that's right. That
book called Joost. Yeah. Boy.
Everything that can made him persona non
grata. Like he just kinda disappeared.
He got written off from that book. Yeah.
Like people just decided, fuck you.
Yeah. That's interesting.
Right? It is. It is.
Yeah. Too much of a
snitch, I guess. Yeah man.
People just didn't respect him after that
because there was so many people that
were also doing it and he was the one
that ratted everybody out and profited off
of it. Yeah. There's some, there's some
justice, some street justice in that.
I just think that there's, we have
to be really careful with call,
but it's just,
there's also an issue that everyone has
access to social media and everyone has
the ability to complain about things.
Yeah. So there's a world, right.
So there's a lot of noise. Yeah.
You get the real sound like,
like there are things that
happen that are really bad,
and when something happens, it's really
bad. Yeah. The Twitter mob and the,
all the people that go after these
people for something that's legitimately
awful. Sure. It makes sense. Yeah. I mean
it's, there's, there's justice to it,
but there's also like this
constant looking for targets.
Yes. That it seems like there, that's
kind of like a hobby of some people. Yeah.
Like that is the thing.